all right, so we've been speculating for a
while that as Donald Trump continues to not
suffer consequences from different events
that take place during his presidency, he's
going to become more and more authoritarian.
The latest of course, was his acquittal and
impeachment, and we anticipated that he would
become even more unhinged and authoritarian.
If Donald Trump were to be reelected in November,
he will become even more authoritarian and
unhinged and acting unilaterally.
And why wouldn't he?
Right from the start of the Mueller probe,
we said this is not going to remove him.
And Trump got out of it a Yasser.
Some of his friends went to prison.
Uh, he's trying to reduce for how long, of
course, as we see with the Roger Stone case,
but why wouldn't he become more authoritarian?
He got away with it.
The 25th amendment, many argue should be used
to remove a president that is increasingly
unfit, temperamentally, cognitively to be
president of the United States.
It doesn't matter.
It's not going to remove Donald Trump.
We now saw impeachment acquittal, uh, Trump
getting away with it once again.
So if you are Trump, why don't you do whatever
you want because they, they can't touch you.
It really seems as though he is indeed Teflon.
Don talking about a pardons possibly.
Now we'll get to that a little bit later.
Remember that, uh, Donald Trump, um, uh, so
to give you the, the reminder, Roger Stone
from associate, uh, was convicted and the
recommendation from prosecutors was for seven
to nine years in prison.
Donald Trump flipped out, tweeted yesterday.
We did a story about Trump's tweet, which
subsequently was followed up by the justice
department backtracking and saying, well,
we no longer recommend seven to nine years.
We just recommend some prison time.
This immediately led to the resignation of
multiple prosecutors on the case who were
disgusted with the way in which this was being
handled.
And then yesterday Donald Trump gave one of
these gong show press conferences and there
is so much to look at here.
A lot of it related to Donald Trump's incipient
authoritarianism.
The question asked of Trump, will you pardon
Roger Stone? Trump says, I'm not ready to
say yet, but there's lots of people who by
the way, haven't been charged with any crimes.
Who in Trump's mind are worse than stone?
Listen to the specific words Trump is using
here and then we'll discuss.
I don't want to say that yet, but I tell you
what, people were hurt viciously and badly
by these corrupt people, and I want to thank,
if you look at what happened, I want to thank
the justice department for seeing this, this
horrible thing, and I didn't speak to him
by the way, just so you understand.
They saw the horribleness of a nine year sentence
for doing nothing.
You have murders and drug addicts.
They don't get nine years, nine years for
doing something that nobody even can define
what he did.
The German buddy said, he put out a tweet
and the tweet, you based it on that we have
killers, we have murders all over the place.
Nothing happens, and then they put a man in
jail and destroy his life, his family, his
wife, his children, nine years in jail.
It's a disgrace.
In the meantime, call me walks around making
book deals, the people that launched the scam
investigation and what they did as a disgrace,
and hopefully it'll be treated fairly.
Everything else would be treated.
So there is so much here.
First of all, notice that Trump said, I didn't
talk to the justice department.
Now we don't know if that's true or not.
Trump lies all the time.
He may have spoken to the justice department,
he may have spoken to the justice department
indirectly, but Trump publicly tweeted his
displeasure with the recommendation of seven
to nine years in prison for Roger Stone.
The justice department is monitoring Trump's
tweets.
Bill BARR knows what it is that Donald Trump
wants.
So this idea that even if true is a mere irrelevant
technicality, that Trump didn't talk to the
justice department, he slips that in there.
Then Trump says, stone shouldn't get nine
years in prison because James Komie isn't
in prison.
Now, that's not an argument.
I believe most of our audience would understand
that it is not a legal argument.
It is not an ethical argument.
It's not an American argument to say stone
who's been convicted shouldn't get nine years
because the FBI director Trump fired to obstruct
the Russia probe isn't currently imprisoned.
Comi has not been charged with anything, nevermind
convicted.
There is, there are few things less American
than suggesting stone sentence should be lower
because someone who's not been even legally,
formally accused of a crime is not currently
in prison.
Then Trump was asked, and this is very interesting,
did you learn a lesson from impeachment?
And Trump says, yeah, I did.
Democrats are absolutely terrible.
Check it out.
The Republicans have said they hoped you would
learn a lesson from impeachment.
What lesson did you learn from impeachment?
That the Democrats are crooked.
They've got a lot of crooked things going,
that they are vicious, that they shouldn't
have brought impeachment and even had that
by Paul numbers are 10 points higher because
of fake news like NBC, which reports the news
very inaccurately, probably more inaccurately
than CNN, if that's possible.
Uh, MSD and C and your ms. and if you take
a look at NBC now, I think they're among the
most dishonest reporters of the news.
Okay.
Thank you very much everybody.
I appreciate it.
Now this actually is logical.
Again, the Mueller probe, Trump gets out scot-free,
believes it's an exoneration.
Even though it's not 25th amendment stuff
isn't going to touch him.
Impeachment, he gets acquitted.
He's gotten away with pardoning people.
What?
All of this stuff, right?
Yeah.
What Trump learned from all of these things,
including impeachment, is there's a lot of
people trying to do stuff.
To me, they're failing.
I feel like it's an exoneration and they must
be bad people because it's all felt like a
huge waste of time.
Now, by the way, um, this issue of, uh, uh,
continuing through our tour of authoritarianism
through Donald Trump's mind, despite saying
yesterday that he did not talk to the justice
department.
Here he is in the last couple of days saying
if he wanted to talk to the justice department
and tell them what to do about Roger Stone
sentence, he absolutely would have the legal
right to do it.
Check it out.
I thought it was ridiculous that, that of
that, no, I didn't speak to the jets.
I'd be able to do it if I wanted.
I have the absolute right to do it.
Uh, I stay out of things, uh, to a degree
that people wouldn't believe, but I didn't
speak to him.
I thought the recommendation was ridiculous.
I thought the whole prosecution was ridiculous.
And I look at others that haven't been prosecuted
or I don't know where it is now, but when
you see that, I thought it was an insult to
our country.
And again, he's probably right.
He probably would be able to get away with
that because he gets away with everything.
And once again, comparing Roger Stone to people,
not indicted, not prosecuted, this is a completely
unAmerican way to evaluate a sentence.
Someone not charged with a crime is free.
So stone shouldn't get seven to nine years
because he's on Trump's side politically.
This is, you know, I, I try on this program,
we don't want to be, but we don't want to
understate things either.
This is one of the most fundamentally un-American
ideas that we've heard from Donald Trump so
far, and if allowed to continue for a second
term.
This is exactly the type of thinking that
escalated by being a sitting duck, by feeling
exonerated from the Muller probe from impeachment,
so on and so forth.
This can lead to a very, I will say an even
more dangerous Donald Trump in office, which
is why we have one recourse.
We have one option.
We have one path to his removal.
You all know what it is.
I won't even say it, but it takes place in
November.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram for more coverage of this
and other stories
at David Pakman show, and while you're on
Instagram